what about the women the women who are
triggered by you who are those women
whales sorry I mean beautiful majestic
creatures that live in the city so
people who struggle with obesity but who
else who else
um
I would say girls that are like very
promiscuous get triggered when I talk
about like body count
um I would say that
oh my gosh feminists hate me they look
at me do you see that panel they hated
me they did they did I have been
perfectly polite you see when she called
me pretty I'm like thank you
she didn't even mean to she's trying to
insult me anyways yeah I would say
feminists girls that like are super into
only fans club like that sort of thing
and well